[Music]
angela is in austin texas angela welcome
to the ramsay show
hi how are you doing great how can we
help
um well this is
here it is uh we're my husband and i uh
we've been debt-free for a number of
years
uh
and
we have a lot of money in the bank right
now and we need to move it because it's
it's it's approaching to a very big
number
how big is this number
uh it's 500
plus 500 000 just sitting in your bank
account
yes and uh
he's uh he works for the government he's
a civilian
and uh so we have income i'm retired
military we have income coming there we
wanted to buy a business
this last two years the covet hit so
we're reluctant to even invest in
anything even even real estate because
right now we're trying to
basically just be mobile wherever that
is and you don't want to be tied up we
have it
correct correct so you know we're now
we're empty nesters we want to we don't
know what we want to do when we grow up
is basically what it is but we have this
money and it's it's not really working
for us and i'm just with the information
coming down with this administration
i'm i'm nervous
so where did this money how did you
accumulate this money and how fast
um
well we
see the civilian we went we went
overseas i've been retired for
about about 10 years so we try to live
on my pension from the military as much
as we can so we went overseas and
he makes good money we just sucked that
away for five years in addition to when
we went overseas we sold our house we
had a little income from there and we
just really live below our means we have
one car
we're renting
um i mean my cars are 2014. you say
you're renting because you're not there
for a while
yes we're looking you know do we move to
tennessee do we go with family in
georgia do we just buy here i don't know
you know so since those are the unknowns
for us we want our money to work for us
and we
just feel we need to either split it up
and put it in different
do you have it in one account right now
yes okay well number one i i
you should split that and here's the
reason
your money is fdic insured up to 250 000
which means if your bank just went out
of business today uh you're backed for
250 which means you lose half your money
so i want you to at least split that up
and you can look into uh
the the rules around can i just put it
in two different accounts or does it
need to be with a different bank uh
check with your bank as to how that
would work but i want to make sure your
money's at least protected right now and
then as far as growing it i see you're
saying hey we i know we can do better
with this money i don't want you
throwing it into um into the market
investing it if you're going to need it
anytime soon and it sounds like you just
don't know there's a lot of unknowns
right now
yeah correct
correct now what you could do is invest
part of it you could you know work with
a smartvestor pro and go hey we're gonna
put a hundred thousand dollars into some
mutual funds in a brokerage account
outside of retirement and just let it
grow until we know what we want to do
with that
but as far as the money goes what i
would do is put it in a high yield
savings account right now you could get
about a half a percent to a percent
depending on where you go
and that would at least help grow your
money in a safe way where it's still
very accessible
okay okay angela how soon before you
guys are going to be locking in on a
decision some of the decisions that you
just shared with us
about where we're living primarily yes i
i think probably uh
within four months if some things don't
work out with a new location then we'll
probably just build routes here buy a
home
uh
and then just write it out so he retires
and so that's kind of where we are
yeah
well and so let's just say that the
decision was made today okay yeah that
we were either going tennessee georgia
or staying in texas
what would you do with that money today
if that decision was already made
well
then i would say we we would we would
take that money probably
don't laugh but just probably move into
a mobile home
on some land and probably fish and live
on my retirement so it just kind of
evens out to be honest with you
okay so you see where i'm going with
this that
i mean you've already got a plan for it
and what it's going to be is it's going
to be cash you're going to cash you're
going to pay cash for wherever you're
going to live and finish out
yes well then i'd be you know i mean
george is right i protect your money uh
in the short term but you guys need to
make a decision and once you make a
decision that money is going to be spent
on paying cash
so you don't owe a dime for anything and
you may have some left over after you
buy a house or whatever you're going to
do correct yes yes yes yeah i just think
you're overthinking it let's make a
decision stop spending all this time
worrying about how much money you got in
the bank which you shouldn't be worried
about anything good on you guys good job
let's make a decision on where we want
to to drop anchor and let's drop anchor
and then spend that money on on that the
only thing i would challenge you on is
the is the mobile home it's just you
know why not buy a nice little home or
build a nice little home
uh something that i say
well say it a little louder seems like
hubs needs to hear that louder yeah yeah
is he not wanting to be locked locked
into something
i i think that's where it is because you
know we're getting older and you know
what i what i thought retirement was
going to be it's not and it's okay i
mean it's a good life i mean we're
moving around we're traveling um what
did you want retirement to be
kind of still that but i i don't i've
been we've been mobile so long with the
military that uh
i feel like you want to plant roots
i do i really do i want i wanted to be
able to say this is home and come back
to it you know i'm originally from
california and uh and i really love his
family and i would like to move close to
them too but it is it just
in the good thing about it with his job
with this kovit
is the teleworking opportunities have
really
it doesn't limit us now where we can
live and he can still maintain you can
have roots anywhere and still and still
be able to do the job
yes yeah i i think all of a sudden uh
angela this this is no longer a money
call this is a marriage call and you all
need to just sit down and meet in the
middle he likes he likes some freedom to
roam let's get him some land pay cash
for it where he can roam and hunt and
fish or whatever it is you guys talked
about but you want to drop anchor and
you need to drop anchor and so you guys
need to sit down as a married couple and
go let's decide
he needs to know that you
uh don't feel safe
emotionally not knowing where you want
to land you want to land you want to
nest you want to
to settle
the difference maybe get it get us a
single family somewhere and get an rv so
you can guys can take off for there we
go you guys got plenty of money in the
back you got half a million dollars just
two of you get build a little house and
it's a nice asset it's gonna appreciate
and land and george it's a great point
then you guys can drive around and when
you get tired of driving around with
each other you go back to the house and
you have home there you go h-o-m-e i
love it well angela it's a good problem
to have uh most of america is like i
wish i had angela's problem half a
million dollars don't know what to do
with it
isn't that true good for you by the way
look at that diligence you hear that ken
they would just say you know what we had
we got money and we put it to use we
saved it up we didn't go spend it on a
bunch of toys we just saved it up and
look at them now what's your position on
those tiny homes that you can drag
around are those basically mobile homes
still yeah they're just hipster mobile
homes so they don't appreciate no ah
okay that's what i thought if you've got
tons of money to blow and you just want
to have some fun make an airbnb live
there for a while that's fine i'm not
mad they look cool on those little hd
it's really cool i would fit great in a
tiny home so i've looked into it you
would you'd have plenty of room in a
tiny home oh